So Leute, ich bin nochmal da, ich habe sonst nichts besseres zu tun und ich bin irgendwie müde schon, echt ätzend, ich sage euch, ich hoffe, dass ich bald wieder richtig gesund bin, das geht mir mega auf den Keks, es ist aber schon wieder ein bisschen besser geworden im Laufe des Tages, also vielleicht,
na gut, dafür ist es in den letzten zwei Tagen wieder schlechter geworden, aber vielleicht hat sich ja alles erledigt, weil das geht mir echt auf den Keks, ich habe übrigens heute nochmal einen Corona-Test gemacht, das ist negativ, also ich habe kein Corona, ist irgendwas anderes, keine Ahnung,
oh, das Sarix ist am Start, nice, du bist so traurig, wieso war es los?
Achso, du meinst in der Welt?
Ja, da haben wir ja nicht so viel Einfluss drauf, da kannst du traurig sein, das wird wahrscheinlich nichts, leider nichts großartig daran ändern, ich finde die Entwicklung sicherlich auch nicht toll, ehrlich gesagt, ich versuche da möglichst wenig Gedanken drüber zu machen, weil im Prinzip ist alles, was rauskommt, Kacke, es hat einer auf Twitter gepostet, habe ich gestern gelesen, es hat einer auf Twitter gepostet,
dass ja der,
Krieg in der Ukraine super Möglichkeiten für Aktienanleger bieten würde, habe ich mir auch so gedacht, ja super, ja, als wären das die einzigen Probleme, die es gerade gibt, Hauptsache Stonksmann, und selbst wenn er damit Recht hat, was ja, keine Ahnung, aus historischer Aktienbetrachtungssicht, vielleicht durchaus sinnvoll sein kann, ist das vielleicht gerade nicht die beste Zeit, es auf Twitter zu posten,
was das größte Flugzeug der Welt wurde heute zerstört, ist das so, okay, ja gut, was, das dachte ich mir schon, aha, komm, das Flugzeug, das ist aber verwirrend, warum heißen die Dinge AN, ich dachte AN ist schon für irgendwelche Sturmgewehre, AN-94 reserviert, zumindest kenne ich das aus Battlefield, das verwirrt mich eh hardcore, ne, ich gucke jeden Tag,
immer auf das,
Ukraine, Subreddit, und gucke mir so ein bisschen die Twitter-Trends an, einfach, dass man so guckt, weil, mitbekommt, was da so abgeht, und, ey, ich habe echt Schwierigkeiten, ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt, ich habe wirklich Schwierigkeiten, die auseinanderzuhalten, die reden, beide Seiten reden Russisch, also beide Seiten reden irgendwas, was für mich Russisch klingt, wahrscheinlich darf man nicht sagen, die reden Russisch, weil dann die eine Seite angepasst, angepisst, oder die andere, die reden aus meiner Sicht alle gleich, die Fahrzeuge sehen gleich aus,
die,
ich kann die denn auseinanderhalten,
ich kann, ich kann mal, was ich will,
und, das geht allen irgendwie so, wenn ich auf Reddit gucke, irgendwie vorhin haben sie gepostet, äh, haben sie irgendwie gezeigt, irgendwie kaputte, kaputte Stadt, und, und, das ist ja, okay, welche, wer, wer liegt da rum, sind es jetzt Russen, sind es Ukrainer, man weiß es nicht, ja, ich kann da nix auseinanderhalten, das ist wirklich grausam, also,
da muss man sagen, ich kann ja wenigstens lang Battlefield,
Ami-Panzer,
und,
russische Panzer auseinanderhalten,
ja, ich, das, das, das kann ich ja so, mittlerweile,
falls die Dinger noch aktuell sind, die es in Battlefield gibt,
und, äh,
das, da kann ich nix auseinanderhalten,
ist echt so unerlernt,
wir hatten mal, wenn ich mir das überlege, wir hatten auf der Arbeit,
wir hatten auf der Arbeit mal,
ähm,
drei Russen und nen Ukrainer,
und,
mittlerweile,
sind die alle weg, es ist nur noch ein Russe übrig geblieben, von diesem Vierer, Vierer-Squad,
frag mich, wie das so ist,
ob man sich dann prinzipiell nicht leiden kann,
weil,
andere Leute gerade da Kriech gegeneinander führen,
die haben ja eigentlich nix gegeneinander gehabt,
tja, keine Ahnung,
eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, ich mein, ich beschäftige mich damit, ich lese jeden Tag mindestens ne Stunde nebenbei auf, auf, auf Reddit, was so abgeht,
aber ansonsten,
versuche ich mir da möglichst wenig Gedanken drüber zu machen,
und,
ja, ich denke, auch die Leute an sich haben nix gegeneinander,
ich hab so ein Video gesehen,
da stand irgend ein russischer Panzer rum,
hatte kein, hatte keinen Treibstoff mehr,
und da kam irgendwie, irgendwie ein ukrainisches Zivilauto vorbeigefahren,
und hat irgendwie gemeint, na,
Treibstoff leer,
so irgendwie so ganz so, als, als, als wär sonst nix, so,
wir fahren mal kurz zu dem Panzer hin und fragen, was los ist, ha, ha, ha, na, Treibstoff leer,
gut, die haben mir natürlich keinen Treibstoff gegeben, das wär natürlich,
ziemlich kontraproduktiv.
Da lachen die im Panzer
drin. Also irgendwie scheint mir das
zum größten Teil nicht
zwischen den Leuten zu sein,
dass die sich nicht abkönnen.
Der hat nicht gefragt,
soll ich dich nach Russland fahren?
Der hat gesagt,
soll ich dich
mit einer Rakete nach Russland zurückschießen?
Hat er geantwortet, ja.
Naja,
aber ich versuche mich da möglichst wenig mit
auseinanderzusetzen, neben dem, dass ich halt
ein bisschen auf dem aktuellen Stand bleibe, über Reddit
und Twitter-Trends und Nachrichten und so.
Ich versuche mir da
möglichst wenig Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Wie hat mal ein
Lehrer von mir gerne gesagt?
Abstand schützt.
Ist in dem Fall auch wieder.
Möglichst weit weg sein ist nicht verkehrt.
Wenn irgendwo was passiert, einfach nicht da sein,
wo was passiert.
Das ist gut. Also, wenn es was Schlimmes ist.
Wenn es was Gutes ist, ist es schlecht, wenn man nicht da ist.
Aber Abstand schützt
in der Regel immer.
Einfach, nee, warum? Wir sind doch weit genug weg.
Hier ist doch wunderbar.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor,
die würden irgendwie die Bundeswehr mobilisieren.
Haben wir überhaupt noch Panzer und Sachen, die fahren?
Oder Leute,
die wissen, wie man die bedient?
Oder Flugzeuge,
die funktionieren?
Könnten wir überhaupt irgendwas machen?
Schiffe, die den Weg finden?
Ey gut, nur weil man
irgendwo Geld reinsteckt, heißt das leider nicht,
dass die Leute wissen, was sie da treiben.
Ab in die Schweiz, da hätte ich ein höheres
Monatsgehalt.
Na, okay. Also, wenn das
bei der Tagesschau einen Ex-General sagt,
da muss ja da schon was dran sein.
Ich glaube, wir haben ziemlich gute U-Boote.
Naja, aber andere
Systeme. Gibt es sonst
irgendwas Spannendes, was in den letzten Tagen
passiert ist?
Bitcoin ist wieder grün, okay.
Ist das jetzt für dich
gut oder schlecht?
Spielen wir jetzt
ESO? Warum sollten wir ESO spielen?
Ich hab ESO in der Beta
mir angeguckt und es hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ich glaube, ich werde jetzt nicht 10 Jahre später in ESO
einsteigen.
Meinung zu Steam Deck?
Meine Meinung hat sich nicht großartig geändert
seit dem Video, wo es zuerst
vorgestellt wurde, weil ich hab mich bisher
weder
da näher mit beschäftigt,
also ich hab mir kein Teardown oder sonst was
angeguckt, noch hab ich mir eins
bestellt, also ich denke
immer noch nicht, dass das irgendwie
die neue Revolution
im Gaming-Sektor ist.
Ganz ehrlich, die einzige Sache,
die ich mir erhoffe von
Steam Deck
ist, dass die
Linux-Gaming-Geschichte vorangebracht
wird. Aber ich mach mir da mittlerweile
keine Illusionen mehr, dass das in irgendeinen
Windows-
konkurrierenden Zustand
kommt oder so.
Dazu gehören ja noch mehr als ein
Hersteller. Und so
krass wird sich das Steam Deck nicht verkaufen,
dass jeder ein Steam Deck hat und du musst es quasi
unterstützen.
Was macht Twitch?
Ja, wir gucken gleich. Wir haben ja
von heute Morgen noch ein paar Dinge auf.
Wir haben ja von heute Morgen...
What the fuck?
Warum gehen die Videos automatisch los?
Was ist hier los?
Off.
Autoplay.
Lul.
Ah, übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich gesehen habe?
Angeblich hat Linkedin einen
JavaScript-Test.
Den könnten wir machen.
Linkedin-Skill-Test-JavaScript.
Können wir gucken,
wie krasser
Senior
JavaScript-Frontend-
Developer wir hier sind.
Nee,
antworten will ich nicht.
Ich will den Test haben.
Weiß aber nicht, wo es den gibt.
Note your JavaScript skills to test.
Coding-Challenge.
Nee.
Nein, es gab einen
Linkedin-JavaScript-Skill-Test.
Wo gibt's den denn?
Ich will nicht die Antworten haben.
Wo ist denn der Test?
Dann gucken wir uns den Linkedin-JavaScript-Test
jetzt an.
Okay.
Ja.
TechnicalSkill.net
Framework. Oh, da können wir auch
machen. Interessant.
Äh, JavaScript.
Äh.
Ähm.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Was sind das wieder für
absolut pepega Hilfeseiten?
Hier findest du ja gar nichts.
Checkt ihr das?
Wo findet man denn jetzt was?
Ich bin da zu dumm. Braucht man dafür
einen Linkedin-Account?
Braucht man einen Linkedin-Account für, Leute?
Dass das funktioniert?
Habt ihr irgendeinen Plan?
Ich bin
nicht in der... Ich finde das nicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo das...
wo das ist.
Dann machen wir den Linkedin-JavaScript-Test jetzt.
Ja. Keine Ahnung, wie das
funktioniert.
Also, wenn das schon so...
bescheuert gemacht ist... Okay.
Man kann sich... Anscheinend kann man sich hier die Fragen
angucken.
Die haben noch nicht mal den Link dazu.
Was? Practice?
Ich will das nicht practice'n. Ich will das...
Hä?
Ach ja!
Ja.
JavaScript.
Gib ihm.
Okay.
Ha!
Okay, das wird ja grausam.
Sind das die echten... Sind das die echten Fragen?
Oder ist das...
Ist das...
Fake?
Mit ähnlichen Fragen?
Nee, das wird...
Practice.
Also, das sind die echten Fragen, oder was?
Okay, also, Leute.
Wir machen jetzt den Linkedin-JavaScript-Test.
Auf geht's.
Da werden wir voll...
Da werden wir voll versagen.
Okay, also.
So.
Which operator returns true if the two
compared values are not equal?
Oh, da muss man ja richtig nachdenken jetzt.
Äh, was
returns true if two compared
values are not equal?
Es gibt in JavaScript
so einen Operator?
Ich würde ja fast
auf den hier tippen, weil das...
Aber mir ist nicht bekannt, dass JavaScript überhaupt so einen Operator...
hat.
Und dass JavaScript so einen Operator hat,
kenne ich auch nur in Verbindung mit Regex irgendwie.
Das kenne ich auch nicht.
Also, von der Idee her würde ich...
würde ich... würde ich sagen,
das da...
weil gleich, gleich...
Ich meine, mich würde nicht...
Mich würde nicht wundern, ist es JavaScript?
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn beides funktioniert.
Aber nachdem man sich für eins entscheiden muss...
Ähm...
Oh, nee.
Wow, wow, wow.
Nämlich,
nicht mal das. Check.
Hey!
Können wir uns das Video mal anschauen?
Bestimmt interessant für dich.
SMS statt WhatsApp.
Der SMS-Boom in Deutschland.
Ja, das haben wir doch heute Morgen schon empfohlen bekommen.
Können wir da mal reingucken.
Oh, guck mal, C-Sharp gibt's auch.
Boah.
Das ist schon gleich viel mehr businessmäßig, weil länger.
Warum ist die so glücklich?
Gott, Skills.
Skills.
Wir wissen alle, dass man Skills kriegt.
Wie man das mit Z schreibt hinten.
So.
How is the for each statement different from a for statement?
For each is callbacks.
Ja.
Only a for statement uses a call...
Nein.
Das for each is callback.
A for statement is generic, but a for each statement can be used only with an array.
Das ist...
Das...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es nur Arrays sind, aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt.
Also ein for kannst du überall machen.
Und for each nur auf Objekten, wo es das gibt.
Ich würde sagen, das hier.
Gucken.
Check.
Hey.
Leute.
JavaScript Senior Developer Incoming.
Was kommt denn nach Senior Developer?
C-T-O oder was?
Gibt es Super Senior?
Grave Developer.
Rente.
Developer?
Boomer Developer.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Okay, nächstes.
Principle.
Was bedeutet ein Principle?
Principle Theorie.
In Deutsch heißt Rektor.
Oh.
Nice.
Rektor Programmierer.
Dann ist alles gut.
Also.
So, wir sollen uns den Code hier unten angucken.
Welches Statement ruft die AddText Funktion auf?
Und übergibt 50 als Argument.
Und wie?
Oder was wollen die wissen?
Die AddText Funktion mit 50.
Wie ist das hier?
Oder bin ich jetzt?
Oder ist das eine Debate-Frage?
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Ist das so einfach oder bin ich zu ppeger?
Check, okay, easy
Wahrscheinlich werden die
Ich glaube, das hat nur 20 Fragen oder so
Wie viele Fragen hat denn das?
What the
Ne
Das mache ich jetzt nicht
Okay, wir machen 15
Wir machen 15
Ich mache keine 114 Fragen, Alter
Lull
Wir machen 15 Stück, dann ist es gut
Elect critical information
Ja
Okay
Let
Rate gleich 100
Das da
Ich glaube, das da geht auch, oder?
Ich glaube, das untere geht auch
Also, das obere
Das obere
Das
Das obere macht man, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
Das untere geht auch
Ich meine, das ist immerhin JavaScript
Okay, check, jawohl
Also, wenn das alles ist, dann ist das aber wirklich easy
Dann ist ja hier Senior Developer Incoming
Which statement creates a new object using the person constructor?
Which statement creates a new person object called student?
War student new person?
Das da, easy
Ja, das ist doch alles
Also, ich meine, ernsthaft
Das ist doch jetzt keine wahnsinnig krasse Skill-Demonstration
Da muss es doch noch komplizierter werden
Easy as fuck
Ja
Okay
When would the final statement in the code show
Was?
Shown be logged to the console
When would results shown be logged to the console?
Was?
Results shown, also
Immer?
Wird Results shown geloggt, weil
Who cares, den Rest hier oben drüber
Oder check ich's wieder nicht
Der Rest hier oben ist doch vollkommen irrelevant für Show Results
Ähm, easy
Easy
Geh ich gleich morgen zu meinem Chef, sag ich will Java Senior Developer werden
JavaScript
Und dann fragt er mich, warum
Sag ich, weil ich den Link nicht in der Karte habe
Und dann fragt er mich, warum sage ich, weil ich den Link nicht in der Karte habe
Und dann fragt er mich, warum sage ich, warum sage ich, warum sage ich, warum Sache ich das
Das muss man sogar Shell verweiten
Das ist das ziav
Und mache wir das
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich möchte eigentlich gar kein JavaScript Senior Developer
Ich
Also das ist jetzt das?
Flofus auch hier.
Dann habe ich, wen habe ich noch übersehen?
Burak Dotto heute Morgen.
X-Slimebeats auch heute Morgen.
Habe ich alles nicht gesehen.
Apatow oder Captain Peng auch heute Morgen.
Ei, ei, ei.
Wieder alles übersehen.
Naja.
Ihr kennt mich ja.
Bist du eigentlich Senior?
Ich habe nichts im Titel.
Ich habe weder Senior noch Junior.
Ich habe gar nichts.
Ich habe gar nichts, was bei mir dran steht.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal,
was ich genau für eine Jobbeschreibung
überhaupt aktuell habe.
Das würde mich echt bis gut fragen.
Das müssten wir mal in Erfahrung bringen.
Okay, also nächstes.
Also wie gesagt, wir waren 15, 15, 15 Fragen.
Und dann ist gut.
Which Snippet could you add to this code to print food?
Oh, Food ist immer gut.
Das müsste ich eigentlich wissen.
To the console.
Console log Snippet here.
Äh.
Moment, was?
Class Animal.
Static Animal Belly Push.
Also, dann ist es A.
Punkt Belly.
Klammer auf.
Null.
Nullter Index.
A.
Belly Nullter Index.
What?
Hä?
Okay.
Was?
Animal Belly.
Ah, Static.
Ich wusste gar nicht, was Static macht.
In, äh.
Ah, also Static ist quasi für alle Instanzen gleich global.
Verstehe.
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Das ist Cheap Bait.
Ja, siehste mal.
Ja gut, da muss man so ein bisschen JavaScript-Besonderheiten.
Ich meine, in C Sharp ist das auch so, wenn Static ist.
Aber ich hätte es nicht daran gedacht, dass Static in JavaScript irgendwas Logisches macht.
Also in der Regel fährt man mit JavaScript ganz gut davon, nicht davon auszugehen, dass es logisch ist.
So, okay.
Also, wie gesagt, 15 Fragen, dann ist gut.
Also, ich habe diesen Code da unten, äh, programmiert.
Okay.
But it instead results in a value of 5.
5, 5, 5.
Was?
Okay, was kann ich ändern, dass dann 1, 2, 3, 4 geloggt wird?
Well, you bet.
Ja gut.
Also, warum da 5 rauskommt, ist ja logisch.
Wir machen ein Timeout und die Schleife bis die, bis, das ist aber auch jetzt implementierungsabhängig, ne.
Also, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt, also du kannst so ein Konstrukt in fast jeder Programmiersprache schreiben,
aber das ist implementierungsabhängig, was passiert.
Also, ich vermute mal, wenn die sagen, da kommt 5, 5, 5 raus, liegt das daran,
die Schleife, die Schleife,
die Schleife,
läuft bis zum Ende durch
und dann ist I 5.
Und
erst nach dem
Timeout wird I gelockt
und das ist halt ein Timeout von
10 Sekunden, dann von
20 Sekunden, ne, ja doch,
von 10 Sekunden, ne, von
20, dann von 30, dann von 40 Sekunden
und
aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo dieses
Timeout ausgeführt wird, ist
I ja schon 5.
Also 5 und 5 gelockt.
Also, man könnte es theoretisch
ohne Set Timeout machen oder
man müsste sich die Variable
wahrscheinlich einfach
gruppieren, dass man nicht I benutzt,
sondern dass man hier noch eine extra
Variable dazwischen anlegt, dass man sagt
Let Z gleich I oder sowas
und dann in dem
Timeout Z lockt.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
So.
What?
Was ist das für ein ekliges Konstrukt?
Das ist doch genau
das.
Gleich wie oben, oder?
Was?
Alter, was ist denn das?
Ah ja, Moment. Das hier würde
funktionieren, oder?
Weil
J
gibt es hier nicht.
Wobei
das hier
das hier wird ja direkt aufgerufen.
Das könnte
funktionieren?
Und
ja gut, J gibt es ja hier gar nicht.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
J gibt es ja nicht.
Dann müsste es das hier sein,
wahrscheinlich.
Check.
Hey!
Five-Hat-Time.
Saved.
How does a function create a closure?
Oh, oh.
It reloads the document whenever
the value changes.
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage,
wie das JavaScript macht.
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Also, das würde erst mal sinnvoll klingen.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und ich kann ja auch die Definition von Closure nicht sagen.
Ich könnte es dir nur umschreiben, aber...
Nein, okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also in C-Sharp weiß ich was.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert.
Die legen unter der Haube
irgendeine extra Klasse an,
also irgendeine, die nur der
Compiler kennt mit irgendeinem random Namen
und machen dort eine
public-Variable rein
für die
Parameter.
Nein, nein, es geht nicht um
Closure, es geht um das
Konstrukt, es geht nicht um die
Programmiersprache Closure, es geht um
das Konstrukt.
Also die Frage, was damit gemeint ist, ist folgendes.
Wenn ich sowas hier mache,
wenn ich sowas hier mache,
oder besser gesagt,
wir können eigentlich das Beispiel da oben drüber nehmen.
Wenn ich sowas hier mache,
wie kommt das i da rein?
Also woher weiß die Funktion,
wenn sie denn dann läuft,
ne, das ist ein doofes Beispiel,
ähm, woher weiß die Funktion,
wenn sie denn dann da läuft, oder wenn sie ausgeführt wird,
auf...
wo sie ihre Daten herkriegt.
Also du musst ja beim Anlegen
und Aufrufen musst du ja
irgendwo dir den Kram speichern.
Und in C-Sharp machen sie das so,
die generieren quasi zur
Compile-Zeit eine extra Klasse,
die heißt dann blub123, irgendwie
Compiler interner Name,
und die Sachen, die du
darin aufrufst, weil du kannst ja zum...
also du kannst ja zum Beispiel sowas haben,
ja, du machst hier oben let i
gleich 0
Output
So.
Du machst dann let i gleich 0
Und hier unten drunter machst du dann,
keine Ahnung, log, ich mach jetzt mal
beispielhaft, machst du sowas.
So. Und hier drinnen sagst du dann,
keine Ahnung, print
print i. So, und jetzt ist halt
die Frage, wenn das hier ausgeführt wird,
wie kommt
das hier dran?
Also sprich, wo kommt das i her?
Das ist die,
das ist die eigentliche Frage dabei.
So, und in C-Sharp machen
sie das so, dass hierfür
quasi eine eigene Klasse erzeugt wird,
sicherlich nicht ganz so einfach, wie ich das
sage, sicherlich wird da was wiederverwendet und
optimierter und sonst wie, aber von der Idee her
wird hier eine eigene Klasse erzeugt,
mit diesem Ding, glaube ich, als Callback,
und es gibt eine
public Variable in dieser Klasse, oder
ne, ne, ne...
ne, ne...
globale Variable
in dieser Klasse, wo dann die ganzen
Dinger übergeben werden als
Parameter und hier dran quasi
gebunden sind, dass es später noch
weiß, wo es eigentlich die Daten herkriegt.
Aber wie das, wie das
Javascript macht, ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
haut alles in Globalscope,
hätte ich Javascript zugetraut, weiß ich nicht.
Okay. Failed.
Ein, ein Step weg vom Senior
Javascript-Entwickler.
Okay, which statement creates
a new function called DiscountPrice?
New
Function DiscountPrice.
Das da
sieht doch schon mal nicht schlecht aus.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob das mit Function
so funktioniert.
Das könnte syntaktisch falsch sein, das weiß
ich nicht.
Das da geht auf...
Oh, Javascript Syntax.
Ne, ne, das,
das muss das sein.
Das muss das sein. Ich glaube, so geht es nicht.
Es müsste das sein. Chat, was
meint ihr? Ich meine,
alternativ könntest du auch einfach schreiben,
Function DiscountPrice.
Ne?
Also normalerweise würdest du es ja anders
da schreiben. Normalerweise würdest du das
so schreiben.
So, das wäre die normale Schreibweise
dafür. Dann wüsste man nämlich auch, was passiert.
Aber man kann
es, glaube ich, auch so schreiben. Check.
Jawoll.
Result...
Was? Result in Console of Running the
Code schauen. Okay, also was, was
gibt der auf der Konsole aus?
WarStorm Function.
Das macht ja schon mal nix.
Storm Prototype
Pre...
Was für ein Ding?
Precip?
Rain.
War
WinterStorm Function?
What the
fuck? Alter!
Javascript. Was weiß ich?
Prototype
NewStorm
Snow?
Also...
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich würde mal drauf tippen.
Ähm...
Warte mal, was ist das denn hier?
Prototype NewStorm?
Darf man das überhaupt so...
Kein Schimmer,
was das macht.
Also ich würde jetzt darauf...
Moment.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert. Ich würde sagen,
es gibt Snow aus.
Aber...
Echt nur geraten?
Hey! Easy!
Easy.
Oh je.
Oh Gott! RegEx!
RegEx, Leute, RegEx.
You need to match a time value such as...
Okay, äh...
12.00... Also im Prinzip
Number, Number, Doppelpunkt,
Number, Number, oder Digit.
Digit, Digit, Doppelpunkt, Digit,
Digit, Doppelpunkt, Digit. Gehört der Punkt noch
dazu?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Would work. Okay, RegEx
stellt's. High IQ Warning jetzt, Leute.
RegEx.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Aber ich muss auch mal in Ruhe durchgucken.
Nicht, dass ich debated werde.
Nicht, dass ich debated werde. Also das sieht auf den ersten Blick
schon mal gut aus. Digit, Digit,
Doppelpunkt, Digit, Digit, Doppelpunkt, Digit.
Sieht gut aus. Ey, würde das
ja auch funktionieren. Zeigt mal her.
Ähm...
0 bis
9, mindestens
zweimal,
beliebig oft, also mindestens
zweimal, Doppelpunkt,
0 bis 9, mindestens 2...
Soll das nicht auch funktionieren?
Ah!
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, dass man
alles, weil die andere
funktioniert eigentlich auch.
Doch, ich will mindestens 2
stellen. Das ist zwar nicht schön geschrieben, also
das hier wäre, finde ich, der beste
RegEx, ja. Digit, Digit.
Aber
ich würde sagen, das funktioniert alles.
Was?
Note, the
first three are all
partially correct and will match digit, but
the second option is the most...
Siehste, sage ich doch!
But the second option is the most correct
because it will only match 2 digit.
The first option would have... Ja.
Das hier ist es.
Ups.
Ich hätte weiterlesen sollen. Fuck!
Ich hätte weiterlesen sollen. Wahrscheinlich
stimmt das nicht, was da steht.
Was der Rest steht, was dahinter steht.
Ne, das stimmt nicht.
Ja gut, das ist doch richtig.
Das ist aber auch richtig.
Hä, das stimmt doch, was hier steht.
Das ist doch richtig.
Ach, das hier ist die Antwort, oder was?
Das gehört da gar nicht dazu.
Ach, das ist gar nicht die Antwort.
Das hier ist die Antwort. Ja, natürlich ist
das da richtig.
Okay,
jebaited by HTML-Format, ja.
Okay, result
console of running this code.
Use strict.
Log this.
This description logger.
Console log this.
New log
this. Also,
Desklogger?
Was da? Theoretisch, oder?
Ich mein, es ist
ne Function. Dann legt der hier irgendwie
noch eine neue
und was auch immer, wie das in JavaScript
interagiert wird, äh, fällt oder so an,
wo logger drinsteht?
Und dann gibt das es selbst
auch, ich sage mal,
drei. Also, window kann ja nicht sein.
Undefined würde auch wenig
Sinn ergeben. Function
kann eigentlich
auch nicht sein.
Bam.
Okay, richtig.
How would you reference the text
avenue in this code?
Was? So?
Ist es so,
jebaiten die mich
oder ist es wirklich so einfach?
Oder wollen die wissen,
oder wollen die wissen, dass ich, ähm,
dass Arrays mit 0
anfangen?
Na, Punkt 3 ergibt keinen Sinn. Das ist kein Object.
Punkt 2 auch nicht. Und 3, 3 ist
Circle, weil 1, also
0, 1, 2, 3.
Okay, check. Bam.
High-IQ-Test.
Result of running this statement.
Type of 42.
Number, oder?
In JavaScript gibt es doch kein int.
In JavaScript gibt es doch nur number.
Da bin ich
mir jetzt aber nicht sicher.
Das könnte auch das sein, aber ich glaube, es ist
number.
Hui, da haben wir Glück gehabt hier.
Okay. Okay, komm.
Bis 20 machen wir noch.
Which property
reference DOM object
that dispatch... Moment,
was? Nochmal, nochmal langsam.
Was?
Which property references
the DOM object
that dispatches an
event. Okay.
Also, self
ist es auf jeden Fall nicht. Habe ich noch nie gesehen in
JavaScript. Object ergibt
auch keinen Sinn. Source
könnte sein... Nee, nee.
Also von der Logik
her... Chat, ich glaube auch, dass
es Target ist. Von der Logik
her würde man sagen Source,
aber es ist Target.
Ich erinnere mich dran, wenn
du in einem Klick-Event... Also es muss Target
sein. Ja, ja. Ich erinnere mich dran.
Wenn du ein Klick-Event auslöst und in das
Klick-Event reinguckst
und aufmachst im...
äh...
in den Developer Tools im Browser
und
du das Event anguckst, dann heißt das Target.
Und Target ist quasi in dem Fall dann
das Element, wo ich draufgeklickt habe. Es ist Target.
Ja.
You are adding error handling. Was?
Der kennt mich aber schlecht.
Error Handling.
Die haben noch nie gesehen, was
ich so programmier. Da gibt es kein Error Handling.
Man braucht ja auch kein Error Handling, wenn man
keinen Scheiße baut, ne? Wissen wir ja.
Wir programmieren
einfach immer richtig. Da braucht man
kein Error Handling.
Nee, aber Spaß. Es gibt natürlich Sachen, wo du nicht
drum herum kommst. Ja, wenn du ein Request machst
und dein Target ist down, dann wird es halt
einen Fehler geben. Und da kannst du ja nichts... Das ist ja nicht dein
Fehler, dass der andere Server nicht erreichbar ist.
Also.
Okay.
Which code
would you include within the
if statement
to specify an error message?
Okay.
To spec... Throw.
Da bin... Also.
Ich rate jetzt. Ich habe in
JavaScript noch nie einen Error geworfen.
Ich leite das jetzt einfach mal ab.
Es könnte auch Exception
sein. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also Catch ist es nicht. Catch ist
Exceptions fangen. Ich will ja
keine Exceptions fangen. Ich möchte ja
einen Fehler propagieren quasi.
Throw oder Exception?
Ich sage Throw, weil ich das
geläufiger finde. Es könnte aber
genauso gut Exception sein. Ich habe noch nie
in JavaScript eine Exception
geworfen.
Ich rate jetzt einfach.
Okay. Richtig geraten.
Wieder einmal
Easy.
Easy as fuck. Easy.
Okay. Genug rumgeklickt hier.
So. Also. Which method converts JSON-Data...
Das weiß ich. Das weiß ich.
JSON Pass.
Wobei.
Wahrscheinlich.
From String kann es nicht sein. Ich glaube es ist JSON Pass.
Ich verwende eigentlich nur Stringify,
weil ich den ganzen Kram normalerweise per
Fetch kriege.
Und mit Fetch ist es einfach awaitResponse
.json.
Deswegen bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es from String oder Pass ist.
Aber Pass ist das geläufigere.
Okay. Easy. Easy. Noch mehr
easy. Easy clap.
Easy.
When would you use a conditional
statement?
So. Ein if oder was?
Was? Conditionals.
Meinen die damit ein if?
Wahrscheinlich.
When you want to reuse
a set of statements multiple
times. Wenn you want
your code to choose
between multiple options. Ja?
Nee.
Bam.
Okay. Letzte Frage.
Oh je. Was kommt da raus?
Hä?
Also.
In jeder normalen Programmiersprache
sollte da rauskommen
0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Aber.
Es ist JavaScript.
Vielleicht lecke ich
critical information.
Aber eigentlich sollte da 0, 1,
2, 3, 4 rauskommen.
Weil 5 kann es
nicht sein. Da bricht ja ab.
Nach den Durchläufen. 1, 2, 3
kann es nicht sein, weil es bei 0 anfängt.
Also das muss eigentlich das
sein. Ja. Okay. So. Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob
das schwerer wird. Ein bisschen weiter unten noch.
What will be logged to the console?
6 Modulu 2.
Ey. Warte mal.
Modulu ist Rests.
Also der Rest
ist 0.
Was? Und dann sage ich.
Ne. Der Rest ist 3.
Ne. Der Rest ist 3. Nicht 0.
Ne. 0.
Der Rest ist 0.
Du kannst es klar teilen
durch 2. Alter.
Der Rest. Natürlich ist der Rest 0.
So. Ähm.
So. Und jetzt.
X.
X?
Ja gut. X ist 0.
Also ist X
False.
Und dementsprechend
kommt 2 raus.
Ja das ist jetzt
JavaScript Logik.
Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Aber 0 ist glaube ich
Falsy. Und Falsy
heißt. Es müsste
2 rauskommen.
Mal gucken.
Hey. Hey. Okay. Das war tatsächlich
ein bisschen schwieriger jetzt.
Okay. 1. 1 noch.
1 machen wir noch. Das ist der letzte.
What line is missing from this code?
Wo soll ich das wissen, was die
vergessen haben?
Achso. Ähm.
Naja. Das Array
initialisieren fehlt.
Moment. Sowas gibt es?
Wait a minute.
Length? Ne.
Das kann es nicht sein.
Das.
Leute. Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer, was es davon gibt.
Ne. Das da.
String length müsste
auch funktionieren, oder? Kann man
String iteraten in JavaScript?
Kann man
String iteraten einfach so
in JavaScript? Geht das?
Ich habe keinen
Schimmer. Also in einer normalen
Programmiersprache würde ich sagen, ja.
Das iteriert einfach jeden
Charakter aus diesem String.
Ne. Das 3er kann es nicht sein.
3er ist ein Object. Und Object hat keinen
Length. Das kann es nicht sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob
Array off oder 2. Also Array
off könnte sein.
Array string to
Array könnte auch sein.
Ich weiß schlicht und greifend nicht,
ob es das gibt.
Ich würde tatsächlich das 4.
nehmen, weil ich davon ausgehe,
JavaScript ist in der Lage, einen String
zu iteraten. Aber
wahrscheinlich liege ich falsch.
Nein, ich liege richtig. Easy.
Easy.
Okay, gut. Haben wir das geklärt.
Nice.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Das muss ich mir mal speichern.
Das ist eigentlich wirklich ganz cool.
Was wird man denn hier so im .NET
C-Sharp Assessment Skill gefragt?
Okay.
What is the example
What is this code an example of?
Hä?
I!
Wer macht denn so Dinger?
Wollen die
Multithreading hören oder was?
Wobei das sehr
painstchampiges Multithreading
ist.
Was schaue Chat? Was sagt denn der Chat?
Ich schaue die ganze Zeit Chat.
Sogar in JavaScript. Nice.
Wo kann man am besten auf Deutsch
JavaScript hören? Tutorial.
Keine Ahnung.
Bei mir im Stream natürlich.
Wir schreiben keine Tests und
keine Dokumentation.
Was ja zwangsläufig bedeuten muss,
wir machen auch keine Fehler.
Also insofern.
Aber ich würde dir tatsächlich empfehlen,
guck dir nicht unbedingt ein deutsches
Tutorial an, sondern guck dir irgendwie
eines der 30 Milliarden
englischsprachigen JavaScript
Kurse an.
Und wisst ihr, was das tolle
an YouTube ist?
Wisst ihr, was das tolle an YouTube ist?
Die haben die Bewertung abgeschafft.
Du kannst jetzt nicht mehr erkennen,
ob es ein guter oder schlechter JavaScript Kurs ist.
.
Ein anderer Max auf YouTube, nämlich JavaScriptAKAIDA, der macht, finde ich, auch ziemlich gute Videos.
Der Herr Schwarzmüller.
Ähm, ich glaube, so hieß er mit Nachname.
Ah, guck mal hier.
Nimm das.
So, let's get started.
Den finde ich wirklich gut, den Typ.
Von dem habe ich mir schon die ein oder anderen Videos zu Gemüte geführt.
Den finde ich gut.
Dann lernst du wenigstens was in fünf Stunden.
Ja, das würde ich gucken.
Den würde ich gucken.
Ist zwei Jahre alt, okay.
Aber, ja, so ultra viel hat nichts geändert.
Also, das, das, das, den würde ich mir geben.
Der ist wirklich gut, der Typ.
Also, der hat wirklich viele gute Videos und qualitativ auch gut gemacht.
Und ich finde, dem kann man gut zuhören.
Ja, wunderbar.
Hätten wir das auch geklärt?
Jetzt, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ach so, ja, wir wollen ja, was ist das?
Er sagt...
Also, ich würde sagen, das ist ein, ein sehr komisches Beispiel für Multithreading.
Tatsächlich, Multithreading wollen sie wissen.
Aber, also ein sehr komisches Multithreading-Beispiel.
A private class.
Das erkenne ich hier nicht, ob das eine private class ist.
Ich sehe ja die Klassendefinition unten drunter, drumherum nicht.
Was?
Ja, das ist ein Potential Deadlock.
Aber es ist, es ist Multithreading.
Es ist scheiß Multithreading, aber es ist Multithreading.
Du kannst das Ding hier mehrfach starten, es ist doch total bescheuert, aber du kannst das machen.
Was auch immer.
Dann ist es eben kein Multithreading, okay.
Dann habe ich nicht recht.
Stimmt, du hast recht, es ist kein Multithreading.
Aktuell, aktuell, wenn man es auf, du hast recht, wenn man es nämlich aufruft, dann passiert erstmal nichts.
Es wird ja kein neuer Thread gestartet.
Man könnte es Multithreading ausführen, ja, ja, das ist richtig.
Herzlich willkommen in diesem Video.
Ah, ah, ah, schreibe ich jetzt so rum?
MonkaS, Mann.
Da war aber ein Zahnarzt wieder, habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Okay.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, das soll ich mir angucken.
Warum? Weil, weil, weil ich Boomer bin und dabei war, oder wie?
Ja gut, 2000 waren die ganzen Zoomer-Leute noch nicht mal auf der Welt heutzutage.
Zu viel gezoomt.
Der SMS-Boom in Deutschland.
Okay, komm.
Weil ihr, weil ihr es seid.
Gucken, gucken wir das jetzt.
Also, wo ist meine Musik?
Ich muss die kurz ausmachen, zeit mal her.
Also.
SMS statt WhatsApp.
Was ist das überhaupt für ein bescheuerter Titel?
WhatsApp kam 20 Jahre nach, naja, okay, 15 Jahre nach SMS.
Es ist nicht SMS statt WhatsApp.
Es ist WhatsApp statt SMS.
Das Adolf-Weber-Gymnasium im Münchner Stadtteil Neuhausen.
Aha.
Für die Klasse 9b schlägt die Stunde der Wahl.
Wahrheit, Schulleiter Wolfgang Geier bietet zum Englischtest.
Und zu allem Überfluss zieht der Pädagoge auch noch die beliebtesten Spickzettel der Neuzeit aus dem Verkehr.
Handys, mit denen ansonsten Kurznachrichten still und heimlich verschickt werden können.
Ja, das war damals so.
Das, das war, das war damals so, da hat sie noch die Dinger.
Handys.
Ja, alle hatten sie ihren komischen Eastpack-Mäppchen, ihre komischen, ihre, ihre, ihre Eastpack-Rucksäcke.
Und ich habe es euch ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Die coolen Leute haben ja auf ihrem Eastpack, also das heißt die coolen Leute, eigentlich war es ziemlich dumm, aber okay, haben ja aus dem Eastpack-Logo ASI-Pack gemacht.
Da wurde dann, tja, man sieht es, man sieht es nicht, da wurde das, das, das E dann so, das ist ein I und, nee, das ist, dann kam dann ASI-Pack, also das E wurde weggemacht und dann, so, und dann, also kommt, dass dann ASI-Pack drauf stand.
Das fand man damals, hat man gesagt, Lullroffel XD.
Ansonsten Kurznachrichten still und heimlich verschickt werden könnten.
Eingeschaltet.
Äh, war es nicht so, dass Lehrer eigentlich damals die Handys gar nicht einsammeln durften, wenn man es streng genommen hat, aber es trotzdem gemacht haben?
Wahrscheinlich hättest du dein Handy abgeben können, vorne in die Kiste oder so.
Eingeschaltet.
Das ist aus.
Ach, Entschuldigung, ja, das ist aus.
Das war eine Spiegelung.
Moment, wenn es eingeschaltet ist, dann dürfen, hä?
Was ist denn das für eine Logik?
Warum lässt er die Leute nicht einfach das fucking Handy ausschalten?
Der muss sie doch nicht einsammeln, der kann doch einfach das Handy ausschalten.
Hä?
Was ist das für eine Logik, man?
Eingeschaltet, vielen Dank, Paul.
What the fuck, man, why?
Die Schülerinnen und Schüler verabreden sich zum Beispiel, um, äh, um auf die Toilette zu gehen oder um mal in irgendwelchen anderen Klassen mal nachzufragen, äh,
wie denn das jetzt nun mit diesem Modell im Englischen läuft.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Das kann man ja leicht bei einem Schüler in der Oberstufe nachfragen.
Wer erwischt wird, dem ergeht es wie Benedikt.
Eine Woche musste der 13-Jährige auf sein Handy verzichten.
Das dürfen die überhaupt nicht behalten?
Die dürfen das Handy gar nicht behalten?
WTF?
Ein Gerät beim Herrn Direktor wieder abholen.
Das kleine Telefon war wohl verwahrt.
Die dürfen das überhaupt nicht behalten?
Habe nicht.
Ich bin nicht allein.
Sucht das raus, bitteschön.
Du siehst, wir haben da mehrere Handysünder.
Handysünder, Alter.
Probierst mal bitte aus, ob das auch funktioniert.
Eigentlich müsste der jetzt sagen, das Handy geht nicht mehr, ihr habt es kaputt gemacht oder irgendwie sowas.
Und sich ein neues Handy bezahlen lassen.
Ja, bis Ende des Tages, aber die können doch keine Woche das Ding, weil bis Ende des Tages, wenn man irgendwelche Tests schreibt, das lasse ich mir vielleicht noch gefallen, aber die können doch nicht, du kannst doch nicht das, das ist, das, das ist mit Sicherheit.
Das ist mit Sicherheit nicht erlaubt.
Alles in Ordnung.
Und prompt meldet sich Benedikt standesgemäß im Freundeskreis zurück.
Ja.
Ohne Handy in die Schule.
Schöne Nokia-Handys alle.
Nokia und teilweise Siemens-Handys.
Welche ist das inzwischen unvorstellbar?
Das war doch deine Schulzeit.
Ähm, nicht mehr, ja, teilweise noch.
Noch.
Ja, ja, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, natürlich, natürlich.
Das war noch meine Schulzeit.
Richtig, richtig.
Also ich bin 1984 geboren, lass mal überlegen, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Ähm, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das heißt, mit sieben Jahren geht man in die Schule normalerweise, ne?
Also, dann bin ich 91 oder so in die Schule gegangen.
Ja.
Ne, mit sechs, naja, ich sag mal 91.
Also ja, dann war ich so bis 2001, 2002.
Okay.
Tatsächlich, ja, das war meine Schulzeit.
Aber ich kann, also die Geräte und so, das kenne ich, das kenne ich alles noch.
Besonders die 15- bis 20-Jährigen ziehen es immer häufiger vor, sich per SMS-Botschaften zu unterhalten.
Es macht einfach Spaß, sich anders mal zu verständigen als durch Briefe oder so.
Oder auch mit jemandem reden, einfach mal eine SMS zu schreiben.
Wie viel gibst du im Monat dafür aus?
50 Mark.
Oh, doch so viel.
Das ist ganz schön viel für SMS.
Aber der Scheiß war damals halt auch teuer.
Die wollten ja allen Ernstes damals irgendwie, was waren das?
15 Cent pro SMS oder irgendwie sowas?
Das war witzlos teuer, der Scheiß.
Richtig mies.
Gucken wir mal, SMS-Preise aktuell.
Der MMS hat nie jemand benutzt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt noch irgendwo was steht.
Was hat eine SMS gekostet?
Eine Nachricht kostet 9 bis 15 Cent.
Ja.
Also ich glaube irgendwie so 15, 15.
Kann ich mich auch daran erinnern.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Dass SMS nicht nur in der Schule ein Thema ist, weiß Ulf Hannemann, Redakteur der Fachzeitschrift
Connect.
Stimmt, das gab es damals auch.
SMS hat einen heftigen Boom erlebt.
Wenn man sich überlegt, vor über vier Jahren, da hat keiner eigentlich so recht mit SMS gerechnet.
Auch die Netzbetreiber nicht.
Da wurde SMS sogar noch kostenlos angeboten.
Aber dann so im Laufe der letzten zwei, drei Jahre, da ist es dann kontinuierlich angestiegen.
Inzwischen sind wir auch bei...
Ja, gut.
Warum ist das kontinuierlich angestiegen?
Weil die Leute jetzt Endgeräte haben in nennenswerter Anzahl.
Ohne Endgeräte keine SMS.
Hey, das war damals richtig progress, der PC.
Und zumal die Leute, ich habe das ja damals auch gemacht, diese blöden Fehler.
Wenn man diese Boxen genommen hat und zu dicht an den Monitor gestellt hat und das halbwegs gescheite Boxen waren.
Da waren die ja auch magnetisch.
Dann hattest du an deinem Monitor neben immer so schöne Streifen.
Guck mal.
Können fast so eine Art Blackberry sein.
Aber ich glaube, das gab es damals noch nicht.
Ja.
Aber diese Boxen waren zum größten Teil mega schlecht.
Das war, wisst ihr, das war die Zeit, wo man sich Boxen gekauft hat für den Rechner.
Und da stand dann drauf 5000 Watt Aktivboxen.
Und das war ein Ding in der Größe.
Wo du denkst, okay, bei 5000 Watt, dann habe ich irgendwie Kernschmelze bei mir neben dem Rechner bei diesem Ding.
Das Ding zerlegt sich in alle möglichen subatomaren Bestandteile bei 5000 Watt.
Also, Schwachsinn.
Millionen von SMS pro Tag durchaus schon.
Die Netzbetreiber gehen davon aus, mehrere Milliarden SMS in diesem Jahr zu versenden.
Man rechnet von durchaus 20 bis 30 Milliarden allein in diesem Jahr.
Damit verschickt jeder Handybenutzer durchschnittlich eine SMS-Nachricht pro Tag.
Kurztexte, die nicht mehr als 160 Zeilen sind.
Ich habe damals...
Da wurde ich gebetet, das weiß ich noch.
Ich habe damals bei einem...
Ich weiß, ihr lacht mich jetzt aus, ja.
Aber das war halt die Zeit damals.
Ich habe damals bei einem GMX-SMS-Dating mitgemacht.
Da war die SMS ultra teuer.
Da hat sich sogar dann einigem...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ausgegangen ist.
Also, ich habe die dann irgendwie...
Weil das so ultra teuer war.
Ich habe gesagt, du kannst mir nicht deine Handynummer schicken.
Dann haben wir irgendwie noch 2-3 Mal geschrieben und dann hat es uns nicht mehr interessiert.
Also, ja.
Das waren halt 2000 drum, ja.
Und doch sind die elektronischen Briefchen für viele ein fester Bestandteil des Alltags geworden.
Für einsame Herzen sogar die große Hoffnung bei der Partnersuche.
Donnerstagabend in der Nürnberger Kneipe Fritz.
Nee, das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Jeder ein Handy samt eigener Nummer.
Seit einem Jahr gibt es die SMS-Nacht für Singles.
Auch heute tummeln sich wieder 300 Leute zwischen Tresen und Kuschelecken.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Mit flüchten Fingern und pochenden Herzen.
Moment, die sitzt zusammen in der...
Das ist quasi Blind-Dating mit SMS anstatt zu reden, oder wie?
Ja gut, warum nicht? Kann man machen.
Ich meine, dann wäre ein Messenger wahrscheinlich zur damaligen Zeit auch schon sinnvoller gewesen.
Das ist quasi das Tinder der 2000er, ja.
Warum genau muss man das über ein Handy...
Egal, ich hinterfrag das mal nicht weiter, wir gucken einfach mal.
Die guten Nokia-Handys.
Hallo, wer bist du? Ich find dich süß.
Und wissen die jetzt, wen sie da sehen, welches Handy der hat?
Vorteil der SMS-Nacht ist, dass ich mir eventuelle Peinlichkeiten,
was man, ich sag mal, landläufig als Korb bezeichnet, erspare.
Das heißt, ich muss nicht auf jemanden zu...
Korb! Korb!
Leute, Korb ist ja mal heute komplett aus.
Ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass das in einschlägigen Pick-up-Kreisen sich nicht Korb geben nennt,
sondern, haltet euch fest, sondern Nexten nennt sich das da.
Und Korb, also Korb ist ja nun deutlich zu oldschoolig, ja.
...zugehen und mir meine roten Ohren...
...abholen und wieder umdrehen und zurückgehen,
sondern ich kann das sehr diskret auf eine gewisse Distanz tun.
Ich find die Idee gar nicht schlecht, also für die 2000er hat das durchaus gepasst.
...vorteil der Veranstaltung.
So typische 2000er-Musik auch im Hintergrund.
...sich direkt an den Korb einzufangen.
Vielleicht gelingt es ja, dem einjährigen Solo-Dasein schriftlich zu kümmern.
Oh, doch, so lang. Das geht ja nicht.
Es ist eigentlich viel leichter, ein Mädchen kennenzulernen durch sowas.
Weil die meisten Jungs sind halt doch ein wenig schüchterner, Mädchen anzusprechen
und da ist halt viel einfacher über SMS.
...doch von Schüchternheit keine Spur.
Na gut, das...
Heute konnte die sich auch kein...
Also, damals konnte die sich auch kein Instagram-Account machen,
wo ihr 50.000 Leute am Tag erzählen, so nach dem Motto
Oh, du bist so hübsch und oh, hier und da und sonst wie.
Das war halt damals auch nicht so.
Da war vielleicht das Selbstwertgefühl noch nicht in...
Abgrund...
...hohen Dingsen, nicht Abgrund...
...in schwindelerhegenden Höhen, ne?
...Nahme per Tastendruck klappt sofort.
Ich habe jetzt eine Nachricht bekommen von der 307.
Sie hat geschrieben, dass sie Lust hat, mit mir zu schreiben,
aber dass sie gleich wieder heim muss.
Ja gut, das ist ja Taktik.
Das mit diesem, ich muss gleich wieder heim, ist ja Taktik,
dass man immer...
Also, wenn der Typ jetzt...
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja, denke ich mal, heute immer noch gang und gäbe,
dass man immer noch so eine Hintertür lässt, so nach dem Motto,
wenn man dann sagt, hier, wer ist denn das?
Wer ist denn die 336?
Und dann sieht man sich da und denkt sich, oh, fuck, Alter.
Ich muss heim.
Das wird dann halt eine Ausrede.
Ja, war ja ganz normal nett, dich kennenzulernen,
aber ich muss jetzt weg, ja?
Darauf stimmen wir mal, wie sie heißt.
Jetzt warte ich mal, ob ich noch was bekomme.
Bedauerlicherweise lässt die unbekannte Schöne nichts mehr von sich hören.
Pech für Andreas und Markus.
Musst du wohl heim.
Dann eben tschüss, bis nächste Woche.
Irgendwann wird hoffentlich klappen, was diese beiden schon jetzt erleben dürfen.
Siehste, paar SMS...
So ist es.
Siehste, paar Mal SMS geschrieben und instant ab geht's.
Profitieren vom Boom der SMS.
Beispielsweise Internetanbieter wie Jamba.de.
Oh nein, please.
Hört mir auf.
Nein, nein.
Nicht, nicht Jamba.
Elektronisches Zubehör für den...
Also was kommt als nächstes, der Crazy Frog oder was?
Handybenutzer.
Bei uns hat man die Möglichkeit, sich natürlich sehr viele kostenlose Services runterzuladen.
Siehste Leute, es gab Hipster auch schon im Jahr 2000.
Da sahen die so aus.
Als Beispiel, wer auf unsere Webpage kommt, bekommt eine Auswahl von Klingeltönen und Logos kostenlos.
Heute, heute wären das hier überall Apple Laptops und er hätte mindestens Kopfhörer um den Hals.
Mindestens mal, mindestens mal Kopfhörer.
Wir haben bei Jamba.de registriert.
Wir haben free SMS-Services.
Wir haben SMS-Infodienste, die kostenlos sind.
Das heißt, ich habe hier durchaus die Möglichkeit, mir interessante Tools, mir interessante Entertainment-Applications kostenlos runterzuladen.
Jamba war so ein Schwachsinn.
Doch längst nicht alle Serviceangebote sind umsonst zu haben.
Ja, ach nee.
So lassen sich bei einer anderen Firma aus dem Internet die beliebten Handysymbole nur über teure 190...
1,82 die Minute, boah ey.
Der Scheiß war damals echt teuer.
Hier, super. Dafür haben die Leute Geld bezahlt, ne?
Benachrichten können der Preis für ein lustiges SMS-Logo sein.
Allerletzter Schrei ist übrigens die Kinderplanung per Kurznachricht.
Seit drei Wochen existiert ein Anbieter, der Frauen via Handy an ihre fruchtbaren Tage erinnert.
So bleibt nichts dem Zufall überlassen.
Okay. Kalender ist out gewesen, auch schon in 2000.
Auch Sportfreunde kommen auf ihre Kosten.
Per Mausklick ein Fußballspiel auswählen, die eigene Mobilnummer eingeben und prompt wird der aktuelle Spielstand live aufs Handy gemailt.
Ausgelassene Stadionatmosphäre will da allerdings nicht aufkommen.
Ja, es gab damals viele Services, die eigentlich keiner richtig benutzt hat.
Ich mein...
Es gab ja sogar die Möglichkeit, ich glaube das geht bis heute noch,
dass man sich, wenn man einen Festnetzanschluss von der Telekom hat,
dass man sich mit dem passenden Telefon SMS aufs Festnetz schicken lassen kann.
Und sowas.
Also SMS, das ist so ein Ding, ich glaub, das werden wir nie ganz loswerden.
Ja, zu beidem, ehrlich gesagt, wenn du ein Android-Handy hast und ich hab ein iPhone,
oder du hast ein iPhone und ich hab ein Android-Handy,
es gibt ja keine andere Möglichkeit, out of the box, ja, über Messenger natürlich,
miteinander Textnachrichten zu verschicken als SMS.
iOS hat iMessage, Android hat, was hat ein Android überhaupt?
Hat Android überhaupt einen Messenger standardmäßig dabei,
der zwischen allen Android-Geräten funktioniert?
Ich glaub nicht, oder?
Google Messenger? Keine Ahnung.
Aber im Prinzip hat eh jeder heute einen oder mehrere der großen Messenger.
I am Jinx, danke für 19 Monate.
SMS-Süchtige.
Die Stimmung der SMS-Süchtigen heben. Das sollen diese drei neuen Geräte.
Endlich wird das Tippen leicht gemacht.
Wie praktisch ist sowas?
Ja, das war aber kein Problem.
Also die Leute konnten damals ausgesprochen schnell mit diesem Nummern-Pad tippen.
Also wenn ihr mal so einen richtigen SMS-Profi gesehen habt,
der konnte relativ gut schreiben mit diesem Ziffernblock.
Das war kein Ding.
Zumal ja dann auch später die Sache aufkam mit Autocomplete und sowas,
dass du dann nur noch die Tasten drücken musst.
Ohne doppelt und sowas.
Also du hast dann einfach nur die Wörter geschrieben,
ohne dass du dann wirklich die einzelnen Buchstaben schreiben musstest.
Mit dreimal drücken und sowas.
Das könnte sogar T9 gewesen sein.
Das hat sich glaube ich nie durchgesetzt.
Und ein Vorteil hatte das mit den analogen, äh nicht analogen,
aber mit den spürbaren Tasten.
Du konntest theoretisch, wenn du richtig gut warst,
du konntest SMS schreiben, ohne hinzugucken.
Das kriegst du auf einem Touchscreen nicht hin.
Zumindest nicht gut.
Naja, hier ist natürlich die Tastatur recht groß.
Ja, aber das Ding ist ja auch groß.
Das war nicht so gut wie an einem Computer.
Das ist ja das Problem, das nimmt ja keiner mit.
Allerdings, wenn man sich das ganze Gerät anguckt,
wenn man mit diesem Zeug durch die Gegend rennen muss,
abends in die Disco, das nimmt doch keiner mit.
Auch im Gewühl auf dem Schulhof wären die Minischreibmaschinen wohl ungeeignet.
Der SMS-Boom bei Jugendlichen ist aber auch so ungebrochen.
Einzige Haken...
Ja, ungefähr so bin ich auch in der Schule rumgelaufen.
Ich hatte meistens eine Kappe auf.
Ich hab heute immer noch öfter Kappen.
Ich mag Kappen.
Ich sah ziemlich genau wie der Typ aus in der Schule.
Kappe, Eastpack, Rucksack, Pulli.
Gut, was ich nicht hatte ist so eine coole Hängehose.
Kennt ihr noch diese Dinger?
Ich weiß gar nicht wie die hießen genau.
Diese...
Die Hosen mit dem...
Mit dem Schritt an den Knien?
Baggy... War das... Ja, doch, genau.
Baggy Pants Herren.
Ja, genau, diese Dinger.
Das ist auch überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt, oder?
Hier, Tommy Hilfiger war damals angesagt.
Ja, ja.
Das ist auch...
Ja, so Dinger.
Diese Dinger.
Diese Dinger waren damals voll angesagt.
Ähm, das...
Das glaube ich...
Diesen Trend...
Der hat nicht überdauert.
Was auch damals sehr beliebt war...
Adidas Hosen.
Äh, nee.
Adidas Hose.
Die mit den Knöpfen an der Seite.
Die sogenannte Schnellfickerhose.
Genau die.
Die gibt es aber gar nicht mehr, oder?
Knöpfe.
Hm.
Ja.
Die... So ähnlich.
So ähnlich, die hier.
Diese Dinger.
Genau.
Die waren damals auch äußerst beliebt.
Heute laufen irgendwelche... Irgendwelche...
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof-Gangster mit sowas rum.
Es ist wieder absolut im Trend, wirklich.
Siehste mal, jeder... Jeder Stoß kommt irgendwie wieder.
Die hohen Gebühren fressen das Taschengeld.
Müsste eigentlich null Mark kosten.
Ja.
Das ist...
Gäbe ich ihm recht.
Das ist richtig wenig eigentlich rausgeschmissen.
Aber es macht irgendwie mehr Spaß auch mit den Bildern.
Ja.
Das Scheiß war in Deutschland unverhältnismäßig...
Also es war in Deutschland eh schon teurer wie in vielen Nachbarländern.
Damals schon der Kram.
Mit Technik haben wir es nicht so.
Aber generell waren SMS-Preise oder ähm...
Auch generell.
Mobilfunk...
Telefonat und sowas.
Unverhältnismäßig teuer.
Es gab ja dann diese komischen Partner-Tarife, wo du sagen kannst, du kannst eine Nummer umsonst anrufen und sowas.
Wo dann am Wochenende erstmal 20 Stunden telefoniert wurde und so Dinger.
Es gab noch...
Kennt noch jemand von euch...
Was war das Tele...
TI-ISDN Plus oder sowas?
Da musstest du...
Da...
Wenn du ISDN hattest bei der Telekom...
Dann musstest du am Wochenende...
Oder vielleicht war es auch nur Sonntag.
Ich glaube es war sogar nur Sonntag.
Das war sogar nur Sonntag.
Ähm...
Musstest du keine Telefongebühren bezahlen bei der Einwahl ins Internet.
Du musstest natürlich immer noch Gebühren für deinen Internetanschluss bezahlen, aber keine Einwahlgebühren mehr.
Ihr müsst wissen, damals musste man mit so einem Call-by-Call-Internet-Tarif...
Du musstest den Internet-Tarif bezahlen plus die Telefongebühren dort anzurufen.
ISDN XXL.
Ja, das gab es damals auch.
Und dann konnte man am Wochenende...
Ich weiß noch.
Ich war damals sehr beeindruckt.
Damals konnte man am Wochenende ISDN-Kanalbündelung machen.
Relativ günstig, weil keine Telefongebühren angefallen sind.
Und...
Damals konnte man sich über Napster...
Ich sage jetzt mal 96...
96 KB, maximal 128 KB MP3s runterladen.
Und das Lied komplett...
Oder Audio Galaxy war damals auch so ein Ding, genau.
Und man konnte...
Dadurch, dass man ISDN-Kanalbündelung hatte, das Lied streamen, wenn man einen schnellen Host gefunden hat.
Also, man konnte den Download starten und das Lied direkt abspielen.
Und wenn der Download fertig war, war das Lied auch fertig.
Das war zum ersten Mal ISDN-Kanalbündelung am Wochenende schnell genug,
dass man quasi MP3s in halbwegs annehmbarer Qualität streamen konnte.
Hast du Elden Ring gespielt?
Nein, noch nicht.
Aber ich habe es gekauft.
Ja, nice, nice, nice.
Du bist ja ziemlich teuer, Alter.
Ja, meine Eltern bezahlen es doch.
Geiler Typ.
Hat er recht.
Ich habe das Fanning eigentlich rausgeschmissen, aber es macht irgendwie mehr Spaß auch mit den Bildern.
Du bist ja ziemlich teuer, Alter.
Ja, meine Eltern bezahlen es doch.
Der ist geiler Typ.
Den Film finde ich cool.
Ist ja auch die Wahrheit.
Niemand hat den Kanal selbst bezahlt.
Okay.
Man kann sich ausschließen, aber die meisten haben den Kram nicht selbst bezahlt.
Du telefonierst im Telefon, hast ein Handy.
Warum rufst du dich mit deinem Handy an?
Oldschool.
15 bis 59 Pfennige pro Nachricht sind zwar nicht die Welt.
Bei mehreren hundert Meldungen im Monat kann aber schnell ein hoher Betrag kommen.
Ich muss jetzt noch was sagen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach eine...
Man ist in dieser Zeit aufgewachsen und so.
Ich muss sagen, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir die Leute hier angucke,
für mich sehen diese Leute komplett normal aus.
Und wenn ich mir die Leute heute angucke, denke ich mir, warum rennen die alle so komisch rum.
Leute, die heute aufwachsen, für die ist das umgedreht.
Die denken sich, man sahen die Leute damals schäbig aus.
Das ist alles Gewöhnungssache irgendwie, ne?
15 bis 59 Pfennige pro Nachricht sind zwar nicht die Welt.
Bei mehreren hundert Meldungen im Monat kann aber schnell ein hoher Betrag zusammenkommen.
Ich hatte mal über 500 Euro Telefonrechnung.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war noch zu Zeiten von Modem und ISDN-Anwahl.
Über 500 Euro.
Bis dann muss die Zahl auf der Rechnung nicht unbedingt stimmen.
So erhielt für angebliche SMS-Botschaften seiner Tochter Diana
Familienvater Jürgen Fay Telekom-Abrechnungen über mehrere hundert Mark.
Nicht Jamba-Sparabo. Ich hatte nie ein Jamba-Sparabo.
Ich hatte nie was mit Jamba zu tun.
Ich habe da immer einen Bogen drum gemacht.
Es kam eine Rechnung von 140 Mark nur für die SMS-Nachrichten.
Wahrscheinlich stimmt das.
Wahrscheinlich sagt er, das war nicht so, aber wahrscheinlich war es so.
Bei mir waren es schon Euro, die 500.
Es kam eine Rechnung von 350 Mark nur für SMS-Nachrichten.
Kann ja sein.
Jetzt hatte meine Tochter natürlich Angst vor dem bösen Papa und hat mir nichts gesagt.
Nach fünf Monaten waren 2.000 Mark SMS-Kosten aufgelaufen.
Und das, obwohl das Handy zeitweise gar nicht benutzt wurde.
Ein Rätsel, das auch die Telekom nicht lösen konnte.
Man sagte mir im Telefonat, es wäre technisch nicht möglich.
Man ist am Arbeiten, aber es ist im Moment technisch noch nicht möglich,
die SMS-Nachrichten einzeln aufzulisten.
Das war die Begründung.
Auch wenn die Telefonat-Nachrichten-Nachrichten
die können die SMS-Nachrichten auch abrechnen.
Also müssen die ja schon registrieren, wenn einer eine SMS-Nachricht schickt, oder?
Was ist denn die Abrechnungsgrundlage, bitteschön?
Telekom schließlich drei Gutschriften übersandte.
Das Problem bleibt.
Viele Netzanbieter schicken ihren Kunden noch immer keine automatische Einzelabrechnung für SMS.
Ich glaube, ich habe nie eine Einzelabrechnung für SMS gekriegt.
... grundsätzlich zu beachten.
Entscheiden Sie sich beim Kauf Ihres Handys für das Netz Ihrer Freunde.
Denn Verbindungen im Fremdnetz...
Was? Die haben für die SMS nur einen Counter, keinen Log.
Das heißt, wenn ich über einen IN32 komme im Monat, bin ich wieder bei... Null?
Ein unsigned IN32, wohlgemerkt.
Also ich muss läppische... Moment.
Ich muss läppische 2 Milliarden... Sekunde...
100.000 Millionen...
2.142.000...
1.142.000...
Ach nee, mal 2!
Sorry, Leute.
Mal 2, mal 2, mal 2...
Wir sind ja UINT32.
4.294.967.294 SMS im Monat verschicken, dass ich wieder bei Null...
Das sollte doch möglich sein, oder?
Nee, dann bekomme ich kein Geld zurück.
Dann bin ich wieder bei Null.
Das ist ja...
Das Overflowt ja nicht.
Das ist ja ein unsigned INT.
Das heißt, ich muss da nichts bezahlen.
Wo sind wir? Stehen geblieben hier?
Richtige, das ist ja mal richtige Boomer-Musik im Hintergrund.
Ja, das stimmt.
Vielleicht könnte man dann auch einfach einen Messenger benutzen.
Ja, passt mal auf.
Ein Gast im Klassenzimmer, der heute bestimmt immer noch da steht.
Seht ihr ihn?
Was ist heute bestimmt immer noch im Klassenzimmer, standardmäßig?
Der Overhead-Projektor, genau.
Der Overhead-Projektor, ihr habt es erkannt.
Das ist heute immer noch am Start.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es heute immer noch im Klassenzimmer steht.
Also sie ist heute noch exakt genauso in der Schule.
Hat sich in den letzten 20 Jahren kaum was getan.
Würde mich wundern, wenn sich was getan hätte.
Was, der Typ oben links?
Der hier, oh ja, der hat richtig Bock.
Der hat ja mal richtig Bock, der Typ da.
Der ist richtig, richtig engaged hier, richtig, ähm,
ho-immersive, richtig immersive hier oben, ja.
Der da.
Der hat richtig Bock.
Halbt.
Im Extremfall müssen sie den Schulgarten umgraben.
Den Schulgarten umgraben.
Das ist überhaupt nicht erlaubt alles.
Was ist das?
Was sind das für komische, was sind das für komische Strafen?
Die waren 2000 auch schon nicht erlaubt.
Doch das Prinzip der Abschreckung, es hat seine Wirkung verloren.
Bei uns hatten die auch so Dinger, die sie immer angetroht haben.
Bei uns haben die angetroht, so nach dem Motto, du musst die Hausordnung abschreiben.
Das ist aber auch nicht erlaubt.
Ein Handy wissen ist ein Wissen.
Wo ist das Problem?
Das Handy klingelt halt.
Der hat es halt vergessen leise zu stellen.
So what?
Das, das ging mir damals auch auf den Keks, dass die Lehre immer so unglaublich wichtig getan hat.
Aber, ah, ein Handy, ja, hm, hm, hm, hm.
Ja, wo ist das Problem?
Der hat es vergessen leise zu stellen.
Dann sagst du, ah, sorry, ich habe es vergessen, machst es aus und gut ist.
Wenn der Typ jetzt immer angerufen wird, ja, meinetwegen.
Ah, das ist immer, es ist das.
Kein Wunder, dass das alles so technikfeindlich hier ist.
Businessboy, der muss Geschäfte machen, ja.
Das erinnert mich an dieses, an dieses Christian Lindner Video, wo er irgendwie 18 ist oder so,
wo er auch erzählt, wie er dicke Business macht.
Das war nur meine Tasche.
Komm, komm, komm.
Na.
Das ist an.
Ein Anruf in Abwesenheit, wer immer das auch war.
Ich schaue es jetzt nicht an.
Sie wissen.
Sie.
Ho.
An unserer Schule.
Sie kennen es.
Das war keine Absicht.
Ich habe es heute vergessen von der Pause.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Sie wissen ganz eisern.
Wir haben da schon.
Das ist eine ausstrickte Regel.
Eine Woche beim Herrn Geil.
Das dürfen die überhaupt nicht.
Die dürfen das fucking Handy nicht behalten.
Das regt mich ja schon beim Zugucken auf.
What the fuck?
Im Tresor.
Eine Woche.
Das kostet das Handy.
Oh, jetzt ist es sogar mehr als eine Woche, weil wir leider Ferien haben.
Nein.
Über eine Woche.
Das dürfen die ja nicht.
Doch, das darf nicht.
Nein.
Das ist bei uns hier ein eisernes Gesetz.
Das darf die überhaupt nicht.
Und selbst wenn es in der Schulordnung steht.
Das ist wie wenn ich in meine AGBs reinschreibe.
Äh.
Jeder, der in meinen Laden geht, muss mir 500 Euro geben.
Es gibt, ich kann viel reinschreiben, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Deswegen ist das noch lange nicht gültig.
Wird nicht verankert.
Nach einer Woche können sie wieder kommen, kriegen sie ihr Handy.
Beim nächsten Mal sind es zwei Wochen, wenn es weg ist.
Das dürfen die überhaupt nicht.
Wir notieren uns das.
Das fuck.
Ja, in diesem Sinne.
Nervt sie das arg im Unterricht, wenn ein Handy klingelt?
Es nervt mich wahnsinnig, aber es ist bei uns relativ selten, weil wir eben diese Regel haben.
Ein Handy, das läutet.
Oder ein Handy, das an ist, wird konfisziert und kommt wirklich in den Schrank.
Und das tut sehr weh.
Also eine Woche ohne Handy, das ist schlimmer als eine Woche ohne Mama.
Was machst du jetzt die Woche ohne Handy?
Wie kommst du zurecht?
Ich organisiere mir ein anderes schnell für die Woche.
Ja.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Spätestens wenn die Eltern da mittags anrufen, ist das Ding wieder da.
Es sei denn, die Eltern spielen mit.
Womit bewiesen wäre, dass SMS-Sucht auch kreativ machen kann?
SMS-Sucht.
Und das ist ja auch etwas, was man in die Schule nimmt.
Man, die Leute haben halt die Technik, was die damalige Zeit hergegeben hat, verwendet.
Die haben es halt sinnvoll benutzt und waren nicht Ultra-Boomer.
Meine Güte, ey.
Deutschland, Alter.
Das ist ja heute auch nicht besser.
Die wissen keine Ahnung.
Die hätten sich damals nicht ausmalen können, wie Smartphone-Sucht wirklich aussieht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Heute fahren die Leute mit dem Auto gegen den Pfeiler, weil sie kurz aufs Handy gucken mussten.
Oder laufen vor die U-Bahn, weil sie aufs Handy geguckt haben.
Da hat damals gar keiner mit gerechnet.
Die Eltern finden das wahrscheinlich gut möglich.
Also das geht nur, wenn die Eltern mitspielen.
Anders hätten...
Ne, vergiss es.
Doodle-Jump, das ist ja auch Out wieder.
Also das ist ja zwar mal kurz...
Doodle-Jump war mal zwei Wochen angesagt.
Vor drei, vier, fünf, sechs Jahren oder so.
Schon ewig her.
Oh Mann.
Leute, ich wollte...
Ich habe mir auf dem Handy irgendwas gespeichert.
Was ich mir gedacht habe, das ist cool anzugucken.
Mal kurz schauen.
Ne, das ist zu lang.
Das können wir nächsten Sonntag gucken.
Können wir nächsten Sonntag gucken.
Ja.
Was?
Was ist los, Chat?
The tragic fall of U-Torrent.
Ist...
Ist das...
Ist da tragic...
Tragic gefallt, oder was?
24...
Ich kann mir jetzt kein 24-Minuten-Video mal angucken.
Ich muss...
Just as the Internet was...
Ich muss gleich...
Ah, danke.
Tragic fall of U-Torrent.
U-Torrent.
Ich überlege gerade...
War U-Torrent nicht einfach nur ein Torrent-Client?
Oder war das gleichermaßen auch irgendwie Tracka und sonst was?
Nee, zweimal Geschwindigkeit können wir nicht gucken.
Just as the Internet was finally planting its roots within computers all across the world
in the early 2000s...
Nein!
... in ways much before weren't possible.
The world wide Web was continuing to evolve.
Mein Boomer-Gehirn kann das nicht, ne.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
zu dieser Zeit, wo wir uns gerade dieses Video angeguckt haben,
mit SMS und sowas.
Zu dieser Zeit war es hauptsächlich Napster am Wochenende,
Audio Galaxy gab es auch noch,
LimeWire gab es noch,
falls, kennt noch jemand das?
Und kennt noch jemand BearShare?
BearShare?
Kaza gab es auch noch, ja, BearShare.
E-Dunkey, ja.
BearShare war doch ein E-Dunkey, klein, glaub sogar.
Oh Mann, das war ein Dinger.
Okay, ich guck mir,
also wenn ihr sagt, das Video taugt was,
ich guck mir den Anfang mal an.
Und dann schauen wir mal, ob das...
Boomer-Video genug ist,
dass mich das jetzt noch 20 Minuten länger im Stream hält.
Ich muss die Musik kurz ausmachen.
Just as the Internet was finally planting
its roots.
Schönes, schönes 4 zu 3 vor M-Bild.
Ah, ist das AOL, ist das der AOL-Messenger?
Ist das noch der AOL-Messenger?
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, es könnte der AOL-Messenger...
Ist das der...
Chat, ihr erinnert euch doch, ist das der AOL-Messenger?
Oder ist es wieder was anderes?
Nee, das ist, das, das Icon hier oben, das ist, das ist der AOL-Messenger, ja.
...within computers all across the world in the early 2000s,
people began to take...
Xo, Xo!
...advantage of it in ways, which, before...
...weren't possible.
Xo, Xo!
The World Wide Web was continuing to evolve,
and so were the people using it.
File sizes got bigger, but for many,
Internet speeds and bandwidth remained the same,
which meant that downloading was going to become more difficult.
56k!
What do we do?
The answer to that question was found in a program,
which dominated computers of...
Na gut, meine Bandbreite ist durch Torrent-Downline schneller geworden.
...hardcore Internet-Users...
Und das Problem an Torrent damals, ich meine, es ist ja, ich...
Ich habe zwar schon lange nix mehr geladen damit,
aber ich kenne den Kram natürlich noch.
Das Problem an Torrent war ja auch die Geschichte,
dass du eigentlich für die letzten paar Prozent
nie irgendwelche SIDA gefunden hast und sowas, also...
Weiß nicht...
Torrent hat mich nie so wahnsinnig überzeugt,
dass ich mir den Stress gegeben hätte.
...the duration of the decade.
uTorrent, this software took advantage of a revolutionary technology
that was introduced only a couple of years prior.
P2P!
The technology in question is in the name.
Torrenting.
And uTorrent was about to become the program...
Oder was wollen sie uns sagen damit?
...that would popularize its use for the masses.
Websites could now provide downloads the size of video game files
at virtually no cost on the host's end.
The Internet was about to change...
Ja, weil P2P, ja.
Das hat ja den Leuten auch die ganze Abmahnung eingefangen,
weil es P2P war und du direkt die IP mitlocken konntest.
Das war halt die ganze PP-Scheiße.
Azubi-Kollege hat damals eine Abmahnung bekommen,
musste eine Unterlassungserklärung ab...
Wieso?
Weil er auf der Arbeit Torrents gesiedelt hat, oder was?
Das ist ja auch schon hardcore dämlich.
...change forever.
It wouldn't take long for uTorrent to become the face...
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das die korrekte Aussprache ist.
Ach so, ich dachte, weil du Azubi-Kollege geschrieben hast,
meinst du Abmahnung vom Arbeitgeber.
Ach, du meinst eine Abmahnung, rechte Inhaber.
Ja, das kann dir, das kann dir gut passieren.
...online...
Tja, und hätte NordVPN jetzt mit mir den VPN-Deal gemacht,
dann hätte ich jetzt sagen können, dass man VPNs für sowas auch verwenden kann,
aber das wollen sie ja nicht.
Und außerdem möchte ich niemanden dazu anstiften,
weil es heute meiner Meinung nach für den meisten Content bessere Varianten gibt,
es zu schauen, als mit Torrent zu laden.
...online File-Sharing, the go-to for all your downloading needs.
Want to finally get that one file...
...you've been trying to find for years?
uTorrent was the solution.
Until things took a turn.
uTorrent was one of those programs that took a devastating fall in popularity.
Jetzt komm mal zum Punkt, Alter, was will der denn 24 Minuten erzählen?
...but not in the way that you might think.
I mean, the numbers boldly stay otherwise, but the people don't.
Alter, auf, auf!
uTorrent went from being a pop-culture icon of the Internet to something that nobody talks...
Auf, auf! Da bräuchten wir jetzt, da bräuchten wir hier Risitas jetzt!
I-I-I-Iaki! Iaki!
Atachankla! Iaki!
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der da sagt, aber es hört sich für mich so an.
...about overnight, due to a series of both long-term and short-term decisions,
which, for a long time, remained unrectified.
Näh, das wird zu langweilig, das guckt man nicht an.
What happened? What happened? What is the tragic story behind uTorrent?
What is the tragic story behind uTorrent?
A program still quite popular...
Das guck ich mir nicht an. Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
...but arguably now in the shadow of its former self.
Now, there was a time...
It had...
Näh, das wird zu anstrengend.
Resident Sleeper, genau.
1,25.
There was a time during the Internet's history where the first thing that people would check during the day were their uTorrent downloads.
Well, for me...
Das ist tatsächlich besser als 1,25!
...I was one of those people learning about today in F1.
As we mentioned, a series of very strange events led to the program becoming both popular and unpopular at the same time.
The number of uTorrent downloads was affected, but not enough to affect competition, though the program itself is just not talked about anymore.
Who the fuck cares, man?
Näh.
Weiß ich nicht, das ist mir zu langweilig.
Oh, oh, der Junior-Java-Developer ist jetzt am Start.
Heute Morgen haben wir den Senior-Developer, das ist der Junior-Developer.
Full-Stack Bootcamps.
Are you recording?
Is this mic working?
Hm, I don't like it.
So, I'm a self-taught JavaScript-Developer.
I learned JavaScript in a bootcamp.
Should you learn JavaScript?
No.
Absolutely.
Here, I'll send you a good Udemy tutorial.
Oh, there's a new library out?
What's the name?
I switch companies around every six to nine weeks.
But this time I'll stay longer.
I can feel it.
I put in a few bugs, only I can fix.
Yeah, we use React.
It's just the best.
Rust?
Hm, I don't know.
A lot of people use React.
A lot of people use jQuery.
A lot of people use jjQuery.
Won't be too bad.
Ist das aber ein Running Gag in seinen Videos, jjQuery?
Won't be too slow.
Hacky?
I mean, that's how programming is supposed to be.
And we're just using a library for this.
And this.
Oder gibt es das wirklich?
Is there a Udemy tutorial for this?
Oh, really?
Can you give me the name?
I've been working with it for ten days now.
I mean, all programming languages are the same.
Yeah, I'm a senior full-stack engineer.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, this, this is just a variable.
Yeah, we're using graphics libraries for this.
jQuery, have you heard of it?
I guess we could rewrite it, but that'd be a lot of work.
I mean, that's what libraries are made for.
I guess.
Yeah, I love it.
It's just the best.
Okay, ich dachte, da kommt jetzt noch irgendwas.
Da war das andere aber besser.
Ihr benutzt auch jjQuery.
Sehr gut.
Was gibt es denn als nächstes dann?
JjJQuery.
Tja.
Ich glaube, Leute, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett.
jQuery++.
Nice.
Ja, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, Leute.
Bett-Git-Time.
Ich bin ja nur noch spontan mal angekommen, weil ich sonst nichts Besseres zu tun hatte heute Abend.
Ich dachte, können wir uns ein bisschen Zeug zusammen angucken.
Und weil ich in letzter Zeit zu wenig gestreamt habe.
Und Leute, ich sage euch, ich mache auch, sobald mein Hals wieder besser ist und ich nicht mehr so viel Husten habe,
Sobald mein Hals wieder besser ist und ich nicht mehr so viel Husten habe,
Vielleicht kriege ich auch morgen mal ein neues Video hin.
Ich habe genug Themen für neue Videos.
Wird echt mal wieder Zeit.
Ich habe jetzt schon 14 Tage kein Video mehr gemacht.
Neues Wett muss an den Start.
Nein, kein Battlefield-Video.
Da gibt es nichts mehr zu zu sagen.
Großartig aktuell.
Sie haben es halt komplett verkackt und bis zum Sommer gibt es nichts Neues.
Der Algo wird dich ficken.
Warum?
Mein letztes Video war auch kein Battlefield-Video und das ist ziemlich gut angekommen.
Zwei Wochen nichts hochgeklappt.
Nö.
Das ist kein Problem.
Das wird erst kritisch, wenn du irgendwie zwei, drei Monate nichts hochlädst.
Dann fickt dich der Algo.
Zwei Wochen ist kein Ding.
Also ein Monat kannst du mal machen.
Ist zwar nicht sinnvoll, das pusht dich nicht im Algo oder so.
Aber du fliegst nicht komplett raus aus den Empfehlungen, auch bei deinen Subscribern und sowas.
Das ist okay.
Na gut.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.